[Music]
come on you got to get on in i've
already announced you on the radio come
on let's go
he's a young singer from memphis
tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome to mr
elvis presley
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Applause]
[Music]
look what you're thinking jimmy
i don't know what i'm thinking
please lord don't let him hurt my baby
hurt him
looks like they wanna
now i don't know nothing about music
but i could see in that girl's eyes
he was a taste of forbidden fruit
she could have eaten him alive
he was my destiny
[Music]
there are some would make me out to be
the villain
of this year's story
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
knocking at your door
as a young singer from memphis tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis presley
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he was my destiny
i wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all of america will
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
what he's saying is god-given so there
can't be nothing wrong with it
martin luther king has been shot to
death
memphis tragedy but it has nothing to do
right
in
with us it has everything to do with us
[Music]
when things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
[Music]
and how are you
[Applause]
i just got to be making the most of this
thing while i can
this can all be over the flash
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
[Applause]
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you